we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p here is a caller who is weighing in
about the youtube advertiser boycott
crisis hey david this is jen and
mississippi look I have been following
this thing about the advertising on
youtube and I just checked Fox News and
CNN Davos still have advertisements I
didn't see anything on MSNBC but I want
to know what is Bob can see any and why
did I still have ads are they not
controversial yeah thanks a lot of
people have pointed out that there is a
lot of content that is just this quote
controversial as our content ads are
still running on it so I don't have an
answer but what we know is we've got to
make up the funding that we're losing so
please go to david pakman.com slash
membership and sign up also do both go
to patreon.com/scishow and we're trying
to get a growing number of patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show it's
another way to replace that lost revenue
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but trust me it's
a good one